here is butler robinson straight on  three  serious questions about his future but  was able to play the entire season last  year for new orleans and  excuse he's really saying this this is  what he wants you to do so having those  guys that can kind of interpret things  for the coach  five second difference game and shot  clock robinson left alone  again and avery bradley who cuts back  door  and finds robinson kaboom  oh darling here's the cut action it's  avery bradley  beating j.j redick back door as he  catches the forces  you you come over to our side that's the  dark side  robin under 10 to start the fourth  quarter they've done  everything that they've needed except  for lead duncan robinson